what's this young all right here's a
young guy here's lee bryce has an as a
question right here
and we'll close it out with one king of
their stinging what's up guys
uh david coming at you from tuscaloosa
alabama
little roll tide action it's not a king
of stinger for you guys
custom jerseys can get or sting it i got
that
brett shaw hitter oh [ __ ] oh
oh wow y'all guys love everything y'all
do
thank you so hey gang gang
yeah that was my authentic cu buffalo
jersey wow that's wild man that's dope
i'm a big fan of the custom jerseys oh
yes you are yeah
yes you are um that's awesome man that's
crazy do you have one of those at home
uh my dad my brother have the game worn
ones they're framed
i don't have one myself did those have
your last name on it yeah yeah yeah
wow damn how much you think it's worth
now
not much not much i'd go this bro
two bond b's okay
jersey come on now yeah i'd be honored
to have one i think it's awesome
i'll tell you right now i'm just giving
you a hard time because i'm just
university of colorado selling them
[ __ ] i need to see a goddamn
percentage i'll tell you that right now
brenton okay how many yards did you have
when you're there
uh i don't know i mean i had some few
catches but i didn't you did yeah
damn did you pretty quick though did you
get in the end zone or not
no never scored touchdown [ __ ] dude
that's crazy who i
blocked the punt that was a touchdown
you did yeah against kansas
why didn't the coach give you more
carries man because i'm white
who was y'all's darker running back uh
um
lawrence vickers and he went on to play
yeah yeah he was
he was a captain for the cowboys and uh
for uh
the cowboys in the cleveland browns he's
the captain of the team wow
it's a pretty cool guy huh yeah great
guy wow
2005 that three receptions eight yards
y'all want a bowl right i love that dude
uh yeah we want a bunch of balls dude if
you haven't seen
the colorado play they play every week
against colorado state and the score is
57-56 and we beat the [ __ ] out of them
every year
bro every every year i will look at
television one night and it will be
ninth overtime and it's colorado versus
colorado state bro and they are
brilliant ball i know we never lost
them we beat them every year y'all
really every year [ __ ] them dude yeah
colorado's state of what well there's
the program just got canceled for being
racist
did it really yeah f that they canceled
the program yeah
like now a lot of people canceled uh
corona colorado state was like
we got a problem because our coach was
saying some racist [ __ ] i guess
yeah damn they say racist things in
colorado
not at university of colorado colorado
state does the rams
damn that guy yeah that guy looks like a
dropping bomb
i don't know man honey looks like
sergeant slaughter
yeah he looks really intense
yeah so they're gonna sit this year out
he looks like squints mcmahon doesn't he
a little bit
it looks like uh
remember sergeant slaughter all right oh
he does look like sergeant slaughter who
said that
nick nick dude one for me
nick finally got one reference fast dude
it starts now through the end of the
year are you in
oh man well let's don't make it
let's don't make it let's make it
through this september okay
or let's do the year because we need
time to do it
[Music]